bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8
week-end émission consacrée aux loisirs
aux idées de sorties tout de suite le
sommaire de votre émission musique la
28e 28e édition de l'estivale de saint
germain en laye a débuté une vingtaine
d'artistes se produiront sur scène
pendant ce festival
parmi eux des têtes d'affiché comme
barbara hendricks ou encore les frérots
de la vega les détails dans ce magazine
forêt de rambouillet c'est actuellement
la saison des amours pour les cerfs vous
pouvez observer ce week-end le fameux
bram de l'animal à l'espace rambouillet
reportage à suivre dans cette édition
cinéma nous ferons un point complet sur
les sorties dans les salles obscures des
yvelines bertrand plisnier le
responsable du cinéma les yeux d'elsa
nous rejoindre en plateau pour nous
parler du film les mille et une nuits
et puis en fin d'émission l'agenda
sportif du week-end il y aura notamment
du rugby et de la course à pied mais
avant de développer ces titres nous
allons parler d'un jeu ce sera une
première ce week-end une murder party va
être organisé dans le parc du château de
la coudre à montigny l'événement est
programmée ce dimanche de 15h à 17h pour
nous expliquer le concept de cet
événement nous recevons sur ce plateau
françoise de celle des rd l'air l'une
des responsables de l'événement mon sort
bonjour bonjour alors expliquez nous un
petit peu ce qu'est une murder party
parce que je pense que tous les
téléspectateurs ne connaissent pas alors
c'est une c'est une enquête policière en
réel en fait c'est un cluedo beaucoup de
familles ont joué au cluedo donc c'est
un cluedo en vrai si on peut dire en
réalité
voilà donc nous l'avons c'est un concept
qui existe déjà et nous l'avons adaptée
à une situation un peu particulière
puisqu'on nous accueillons beaucoup de
monde et que ça se fait en extérieur
alors qu'il arrive souvent que ça se
fasse en intérieur donc ça que les deux
grandeurs nature et à en créer de
grandes arnaques et il y aura de
nombreux personnages ce qu'on appelle
les pnj c'est ça les participants bons
joueurs voilà alors il y aura treize
personnages et il y à une centaine de
joueurs puisque nous connaissons un vif
succès on a eu un accueil excellent de
la part du public donc nous sommes même
obligés de refuser beaucoup de personnes
qui ont l'air très déçu de pas pouvoir
participer à cette première édition les
pnj seront déguisés peut-être savoir les
pays
les pnj sont pas vraiment déguisés ils
sont accessoirisé parce que on situ ça
de façon contemporaine donc ils sont pas
déguiser mais c'est vrai que comme nous
ne sommes pas des professionnels donc on
va céder de certains accessoires pour se
donner une contenance ou pour rentrer
mieux dans les personnages mais parmi
eux il y aura un certain robert
cadalbert donc l'ancien président de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
comment vous avez réussi à le convaincre
de participer à ce grand jeu
ah ça n'a pas été difficile du tout on
lui a présenté le jeu de façon amicale
voilà lors d'une conversation sans aucun
rapport et il a été tenté par parle
aventure lui aussi comme nous tous donc
c'est vrai qu'il a été il a tout de
suite proposé de faire partie de notre
équipe
ensuite il vous a dit oui oui oui tout à
fait et d'où vous est venue l'idée de
cette majeure partie alors cessé veut
l'idée est venue d'un des objectifs de
notre association en fait je suis la
présidente d'une association qui
s'appelle tout ce qui lie qui est une
très jeune association qui a à peine un
an et qui visait à créer des
partenariats inter associatif on a
remarqué que très souvent les
associations ont chacune leurs activités
souvent c'est un travail déjà assez
lourde gérer chacun son activité et elle
ne se regroupe pas donc nous avons
essayé depuis l'année dernière de faire
des actions inter associative et là nous
nous sommes dit que nous pourrions nous
associer avec une compagnie de théâtre
pour créer cet événement
donc ce sont deux idées qui sont
télescopés faire jouer le plus grand
nombre et le faire de façon un petit peu
professionnel avec une compagnie de
théâtre
je suppose que cette organisation vous a
demandé beaucoup de temps c'est ça le
temps de retrouver de trouver les
joueurs les pnj les fameux pnj etc
ça vous a demandé beaucoup de temps
c'est vrai que c'est assez chronophage
mais comme tout comme tout événement
qu'on veut créer et c'est extrêmement
sympathique parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ne se connaissaient pas et qui
est qui qui travaillent ensemble c'est
voilà la démarche elle même est déjà un
plaisir avant même le jeu de dimanche
c'est une première je le disais tout à
l'heure est ce qu'il y aura beaucoup de
monde pour cette première alors nous
nous avons refusé depuis depuis trois
jours nous refusons beaucoup de
personnes parce qu'on s'était mis comme
chiffre limite 100 personnes et nous
l'avons largement dépassé donc voilà le
jeu le jeu est au complet pour le nombre
de joueurs mais nous ferons une autre
édition vu le succès c'est donc qu'il ya
une vraie envie de jouer pour pour les
habitants de notre territoire et c'est
plutôt des familles qui se sont inscrits
peut être beau pour sochaux je crois que
c'est très tôt c'est tout public tous
âges
voilà toute configuration c'est un jeu
qui se joue en équipe donc c'est aussi
le moyen de lier connaissance pendant le
jeu donc c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'extrêmement interactif donc vous le
disais c'est complet est ce que quand
même on pourrait assister à ce cluedo
géant alors ce qu'on a proposé à
quelques personnes s'est éventuellement
de venir se promener d'autant qu'il fera
beau donc c'est une belle occasion de
venir se promener dans le parc de la
coudre et comme ça de sentir un petit
peu l'ambiance du jeu et de prendre un
petit air de jeu éventuellement et vous
disais il y aura d'autres meurent de
repartir et nous bien sûr nous allons
programmer une murder party d'ici
quelques mois à nouveau le succès est
toujours sur le même principe toujours
la même chose où il y aura peut-être des
petits aménagements alors y aura
sûrement un aménagement déjà sur
l'organisation c'est à dire qu'on
essaiera de le faire à l'intérieur et
non pas à l'extérieur parce que déjà là
c'était un petit peu risqué donc on
s'avance vers une saison moins propice
donc on essaiera de le faire en
intérieur et puis de tout renouveler
donc voilà nous allons y retravailler
merci beaucoup
j'espère qu'il y aura beaucoup de monde
pour cette première on va pardon c'est
gagné merci bien
on va maintenant parler musique dans le
site youtube
c'est l'un des plus grands festivals des
yvelines l'estival de
saint-germain-en-laye vient de débuter
pour cette 28e édition des têtes
d'affiché comme barbara hendricks ou
encore les frérots de la vega se
produiront sur scène
un reportage de sephora namani et
d'élodie moelle 28e édition pour
l'estival de saint germain en laye un
festival éclectique qui défend la
chanson francophone sous toutes ses
formes jusqu'au 10 octobre
on est en france que je pense que la
plupart des jeunes qui viennent au
spectacle aime bien aussi comprendre ce
que leur disent les artistes on l'a bien
vu là avec alexis hk ou marché là où
your chauffe pour les buts ce festival
quand il ya des paroles qu elles sont
intelligentes et qu'elles peuvent
apporter quelque chose aux jeunes et
avec une belle poésie on préfère que ça
soit en français 18 concerts pour faire
découvrir de jeunes talents qui
partagent l'affiché aux côtés de
célébrités telles que barbara hendricks
brigitte alexis hk mj les frérots de la
vega ou encore daphné et clarika dans
leur spectacle en poésie et en chansons
ivresse et des évasions quoi l'évasion
les tourbillons et les vrais amoureux
c'est c'est un thème très très vaste en
fait et très musical déjà également dans
le fond dans le propos de la
transgression sinon les dresse donc donc
c'est toujours intéressant voilà c'est
un tony pullis oui à planoise
ça bouillonne s'est passé en mouvement
voilà way
là
à
tous les ans l'équipe de l'estival met
en lumière le travail d'une association
caritative ou humanitaire en lui
apportant un soutien médiatique et
financier par la vente de produits
dérivés du festival cette année c'est
les bouchons d'amour savez les petits
bouchons qu'on récupère qui permettent à
des jeunes handicapés d'avoir un
fauteuil ou d'avoir par exemple un chien
qui qui vient s'occuper de 50,2 je crois
un mission pour la personne handicapée
tu veux battre demain
en attaque ruscino joueront la rentrée
c'est actuellement la saison des amours
pour les cerfs dans les bois vous avez
peut-être entendu son brame
caractéristiques de cette période à
l'espace rambouillet des visites sont
organisées ce week-end pour observer les
animaux et les écouter mais il faut
s'armer de patience un reportage de
camille lambert et de mélanie poker tous
les ans de fin août à début octobre un
râle profond résonne dans les bois c'est
le brame du cerf à cette saison des
amours les mâles ce défi en combat pour
régner sur une harde de biche jusqu'à
l'épuisement à la fin du brame les
animaux qui ont les malts ont participé
activement à ce drame ils sont
extrêmement affaibli et certains ils
peuvent perdre jusqu'à 25 % de leur
poids
c'est pas une tête de plaisir total
magna pour cheuvreux d'un sanglier près
de 200 grands animaux peuple c'est 250
hectares clôturés de l'espace
rambouillet la densité et 10 à 15%
supérieure à celle d'une forêt classique
mais à cette période c'est bien le sert
qui est la star photographe et amoureux
de la nature se pressent pour écouter le
roi de la forêt patients ces
observations sont les maîtres mots pour
un conseil c'est de prendre du temps
donc c'est d'avoir au moins un divan
sacré 3 4h de venir ici enfin à sauvages
alors l'idéal c'est de
de pouvoir accompagner des visites le
matin tôt en soirée cd période de
concentration va dire pour le brame mais
sinon c'est aussi possible en visite
livre la journée mais la nuit quand même
dramé mais là je le répète il faut au
moins avoir deux heures pour ce post est
observée est passion si certains
visiteurs n'ont pas réussi à entendre le
brame la rencontre avec les animaux
restent toujours un moment
d'émerveillement en septembre 2014
ils étaient 7000 à venir les observer
vous voulez transformer ou aménager
votre jardin cet événement pourrait vous
donner quelques idées et astuces un
concours paysagiste est programmé
jusqu'à ce dimanche à magny les hameaux
aux jardins de la vallée
quatre écoles yvelinoise à la main verte
et l'esprit créatif on s'opposer pour
remporter la compétition pour nous
parler de cet événement nous recevons
sur ce plateau le responsable directeur
des jardins de la vallée etienne désir
bonjour bonjour alors pourquoi organiser
cet événement alors c'est un événement
qui met qui permet de concourir cette
école de paysages et l'idée c'est de
deux mètres de mettre en valeur la part
la créativité de ses élèves paysagiste
et justement c'est peut-être un projet
pédagogique avant tout pour ses écoles
oui on leur demande d'abord sur un sujet
imposé de créer un jardin de a à z et
au sein d'une entreprise et donc dans
quelque part dans le monde réel donc ils
vont commencer à dessiner ça sera
validée par notre bureau d'études
donc là il ya déjà une un échange avec
le bureau d'études
et puis après ça va être la même chose
avec avec les installateurs sur le
jardin et on les confronte en fait au
monde de l'entreprise en c'est ça
l'objectif c'est ça donc ils vont
retrouver à travers toute la création de
leur jardin les différents postes et
intervenants dans une entreprise pour
arriver au même résultat c'est à dire le
dessinateur au bureau d'études
le conducteur de travaux après pour la
mise en oeuvre et après les ouvriers qui
réalise effectivement le jardin et
est-ce qu'il ya un véritable esprit de
compétition où on va dire que chacun
veut réaliser un jardin un beau jardin
tout simplement
alors la présente et b les deux en fait
on s'est aperçu que finalement les
écoles se prenait vraiment au jeu et je
dirais même les élèves mais autant aussi
les enseignants ça c'était assez marrant
et vous est-ce que vous êtes super faire
un petit peu parce qu'il propose
ouais on aperçoit sur les images c'est
vrai que c'est quand même assez détaillé
quand même c'est déjà demain quand même
digne des professionnels
cette année on est vraiment on a été
impressionné de de la qualité des
aménagements et puis de l'investissement
des élèves ou alors vraiment très très
investit donc cette année vous avez
choisi
le thème jardins de demain 15 heures de
demain voilà donc alors comme thème il
ya les jardins déconnecté il ya les
jardins connectés il y a le jardin
avec avec le jardin de récupération sur
l'écologie voilà alors chacun choisit
son thème il ya pas mal de thèmes
différents
voilà et c'est vraiment poussé jusqu'au
bout
et est-ce qu'il ya un projet peut-être
qui vous a marqué en particulier
peut-être votre favori sur cette
compétition
et bien justement c'est très compliqué
alors c'est très compliqué parce que
franchement vu la qualité des voilà les
sujets sont diverses donc c'est déjà
difficile de les départager
mais la qualité des jardins fait que je
suis content de ne pas avoir à choisir
et ça sera aux visiteurs de choisir
oui justement au niveau niveau du vote
ça sera les visiteurs c'est ça qui est
vrai les visiteurs qui votent voilà dans
une urne et puis et puis on leur
transmet les résultats la semaine
prochaine mais également les élèves
eux-mêmes choisissent un projet autre
que le leur
c'est ça exactement ils vont noter leurs
petits camarades
et on va faire après un petit débriefing
sur chaque jardin et chaque école va
venir apporter une petite critique à
l'aménagement de ce jardin voilà
et ça ça la note ils vont s'auto notez
donc du coup ça vient en complément du
vote des visiteurs et le gagnant sera
désigné caen lundi on sera les résultats
les écoles sont invités lundi à
connaître ce résultat ainsi que leurs
enseignants
et est ce que le public va être surpris
à votre avis ce week-end je pense que
oui je pense que oui voilà alors rien
dévoilé mais je pense que chaque jardin
est vraiment très créatif sa tenue et
vous attendez du monde sur ce sur ce
week-end oui surtout qu'il fait beau
donc ça aide
voilà ça aide on aimerait avoir 800
visiteurs vous aviez 500 visiteurs ses
salles à l'ancien 50 ouais on aimerait
bien avoir 800 cette année en 30
secondes est ce que vous pouvez nous
donner envie de venir ce week end voir
voir ce concours oui bah le jeudi à
toutes les personnes jeudi aux jeunes
qui ne savent pas ce qu'ils veulent
faire comme métier venez voir ce que
c'est que paysagiste parce que c'est
vraiment un métier qui est créatif qui
est manuel aux personnes qui voudraient
avoir un jardin bien sûr venez voir ce
qu'un paysagiste est capable de créer
pour vous vous pouvez très très très
très surpris
voilà et puis aux plus petits vous pour
vous il y aura de quoi vous amuser
avec des animations pourraient même
faire des petits anges en voilà sous
surveillance bien sûr merci à vous
d'être passé sur ce plateau on vous
souhaite d'avoir le maximum de monde
possible
logiquement ça devrait aller vu le temps
comme vous l'avez dit voilà en passe en
passe maintenant à notre rubrique
littérature direction à présent le pavé
du canal comme chaque semaine la libre
et vous fait découvrir un nouveau roman
cette semaine zoom sur nous louer roi
dave de castro à un livre historique sur
les derniers jours de la vie du roi
soleil louis xiv alors il ya eu beaucoup
de livres qui sortent actuellement sur
le tricentenaire de la mort de louis xiv
et donc nous on en a sélectionné un
parmi ceux là donc c'est celui ci qui
raconte finalement les dames les 17
derniers jours de la vie du roi du roi
soleil on lit habituellement toute sa
vie avant ses 17 du jour là donc tous
ses fastes la construction du château la
vie avec la reine où la vie avec ses
maîtresses mais on a rarement le pan de
lorsque louis xiv finalement était en
détresse et avait des vraies douleurs
donc là ce livre va détailler justement
toute cette partie là de sa vie qui
avait finalement très peu connu et donc
le bouquin est dissocié en deux parties
dont il ya des partis ils ou
l'auteur décrit tout ce qu'il vit durant
sa journée donc tout ce que la cour peut
lui apporter
et toutes les parties qui sont aussi qui
concerne la nuit où là on va le roi
repart en introspection avec dieu avec
tous finalement tout ce qu'il a pu vivre
par ailleurs c'est une vision qui n'est
pas habituel de de ce qu'on peut avoir
comme comme vue sur le roi soleil
finalement donc cette vision d'un homme
qui à la gangrène qui le ronge
totalement les eaux est finalement qu il
y a beaucoup de doutes
alors il a fait beaucoup de guerre il a
eu beaucoup de beaucoup de choses dans
sa vie où il avait des idées très
arrêtées elle a finalement ils se sont
un peu perdus quand on finalement arrive
la fin de sa vie projet est en ce moment
sur ses écrans le film les mille et une
nuits de michel gomes pour nous parler
de ce long métrage nous recevons sur ce
plateau
bernard pinet justement le responsable
des yeux d'elsa de bertrand pillé par
excusez moi le responsable et dalsa de
saint-cyr-l'ecole bonjour bonjour alors
expliquer non un petit peu ce coup de
coeur c'est vraiment un coup de coeur ce
film pro
oui c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une
particulier c'est un film qu'on a
attendu avant de passe il est sorti cet
été
il a été présenté en mai dernier à
cannes à la quinzaine des réalisateurs
il a eu son petit succès évidemment et
puis il est sorti juste à l'ouverture de
l'été et c'était pas forcément la
meilleure période pour nous pour le
passé donc on ne propose un peu plus
tard maintenant avec
le temps pour pouvoir le découvrir parce
que c'est un film qui demande un peu de
temps
et qu'est ce qui vous a plu justement
dans ce film qu'est ce qui vous a touché
la l'imaginaire du réalisateur qui est
vraiment un imaginaire très fort ce
qu'ils disent qu'il plaît c'est tout
simplement la folie c'est ce qu'on peut
faire c'est un film qui nous montre tout
ce qu'on peut faire avec le cinéma
évidemment on à dire ça on est plus
habitué aux effets spéciaux à toutes ces
choses là mais le cinéma c'est avant
tout à lang un langage c'est avant tout
une manière de s'exprimer une manière de
créer de la poésie et là c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un film qui est de ce
type là c'est un film qui entrent dans
lequel on entre par la voie du
documentaire puisque c'est un film qui
se déroule au portugal en 2012 2013 qui
a été tourné pendant pendant que le
portugal vivait un moment d'austérité un
peu difficile même très difficile pour
les portugais et le réalisateur avait
envie de filmer ça et puis en même temps
il n'avait pas envie de filmer que ça
donc il a il a essayé de créer d'autres
d'autres et des bancs et de mettre ça
dans quelque chose de plus grand et quoi
de plus grand que les mille et une nuits
finalement et est ce que c'est un film
qui correspond totalement à la politique
d'aidé à saint-cyr-l'ecole la
programmation les alsaciens sans l'école
nous complètement
c'est exactement le genre de film qu'on
souhaite défendre
notre rôle en tant que cinéma municipal
et cinéma d'art et essai c'est d'être de
proposer la plus grande diversité
possible à nos spectateurs
donc ça va évidemment du dernier mission
impossible évidemment qu'on passera star
wars
parce que c'est aussi ça le cinéma et
que c'est un cinéma qui me plaît qu'il
nous plaît
mais c'est aussi les films plus fragile
qu'on a pour mission de défendre et est
ce que c'est un film que vous
recommander à tout le monde
évidemment c'est un film que je
recommande à tout le monde
les plus jeunes il n'y comprendront pas
forcément grand chose mais mai à partir
de 12 15 ans on peut tout à fait avoir
envie de 10 entrées il faut simplement à
y aller avec un esprit très ouvert
puisque c'est un film qui n'est pas un
film mais qui est trois films c'est
trois films de deux heures qu'on propose
du coup pendant tout le mois d'octobre
pour permettre aux gens de d'y aller un
peu quand ils veulent et puis de faire
le chemin dans ce film là
donc oui n'importe qui peut y aller il
faut simplement avoir l'esprit ouvert
pour recevoir des choses surprenantes et
vous recommander ce film bad est un peu
pour les enfants ou les adolescents eux
où ils vont avoir une certaine faut
avoir une malle résister aux graphiques
il faut avoir pas forcément une culture
cinématographique mais une certaine
maturité
c'est un film qui comme je vous le
disais commence par la voie du
documentaire donc on y entre par des
problématiques sociales etc
et puis très vite on va tomber dans un
récit fantastique un peu absurde et en
même temps et en même temps inspiré de
la réalité de ce que ce que peuvent être
les négociations entre dun
entre un pays et des institutions
mondiales type bce fmi évidemment tous à
recréer dans un environnement un peu un
peu différent recréer autour d'une table
voilà et puis et puis le film va nous
faire voyager comme ça d'histoires en
histoires
mené par une chaire à une shéhérazade
une femme très très belle qui joue
plusieurs rôles d'ailleurs dans tous ces
films là et puis et qui va donc nous
emmener nous emmener à la rencontre de
gens réels mais aussi de figure
fantasmée dans des dans des récits aussi
originaux que le juge le tribunal qui se
met en place contre un coq qui chante
trop tôt le matin des gens qui vont
prendre un bain du 1er janvier des
ouvriers licenciés qui vont se réunir
une dernière fois pour aller pour aller
faire un à prendre un bain du 1er
janvier tous ensemble l'histoire d'un
homme qui aurait été exclu de sa caste
et qui vont la vivre est comme ça un peu
sauvage dans la garrigue et qui grâce à
la magie du cinéma post et les
transporter par exemple donc c'est toute
cette folie là qu'il ya dans ce film là
et quels sont les retours des premières
personnes qui aiment et qu'ils ont vu
leur cinéma surprises et des avis très
tranché en fait
pardon des avis très tranché tout
simplement parce que il y a des gens qui
vont avoir la curiosité suffisante pour
y aller et qui vont être complètement
décontenancé par ce qu'ils ont vu parce
que c'est pas du tout le cinéma auquel
il s'attendait ou auxquels ils sont
habitués
et puis ya des gens qui vont être dans
la bonne démarche c'est à dire une
démarche d'ouverture où on vient au
cinéma pour passer deux heures d'amer
d'émerveillement et l'émerveillement
c'est pas que les paillettes mais tu
sais ça peut être aussi une manière de
raconter comme quand on ouvre un roman
on peut avoir envie d'être dans un récit
très linéaire est très simple on peut
aussi avoir envie d'être dans un récit
plus complexe plus poétique plus fous
donc on l'a compris bertrand c'est un
film qu'il faut absolument aller voir
mais c'est un peu c'est un film qu'il
faut absolument aller voir aussi parce
que c'est un film qu'il faut soutenir et
qu'il faut avoir la curiosité d'aller
le vers lequel il faudra la curiosité
d'aller un film qui est trois films donc
merci beaucoup
verdier on reste dans le thème du cinéma
que pensez-vous des films qui sont
sortis cette semaine dans les salles
obscures
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
spectateurs yvelinois après les séances
très bons films ont passé deux heures
plus penser à vos soucis est vraiment
vous rigolez en même temps c'est un
petit peu un film madame laethem un
message est donc vous pouvez penser à
part certaines choses et puis vous en
même temps vous rigolez vous passer un
bon moment qui était divertissant et il
ya beaucoup d'espoir et d'amour à
l'intérieur donc c'est vraiment
intéressant
j'ai vraiment aimé ça s'était très bien
un petit peu triste et par an par moment
parce que vont me demande si ça arrive à
s'en sortir notre petit payet a dû bien
rigoler mais enfin c'est drôle mais tout
autant tout autant touchant que drôle
voilà
bah écoutez moi je sais pas s'il s'en
remettront et l'un et l'autre un terrain
l'avenir le dira moi je dirais que c'est
un film psychologique
il ya une tension une tension énorme il
ya de la violence très forte violence
des courts instants mais très très fort
après la fin nous laisse un peu sur
notre faim après cette page cinéma ou
pas ce rendez vous sportif du week-end
dans le département on commet cet agenda
sport part du rugby la rencontre entre
saint quentin en yvelines et les mureaux
en promotion d'honneur est programmée ce
dimanche à 15 heures au stade du bout
des clous à mort par le ska et rugby
dans une forme optimale les joueurs
saint quentinois viennent de remporter
leurs deux premiers matchs de la saison
pour ce derby vinoy ils auront fort à
faire les mureaux les talonnent au
classement
le sky tentera d'imposer son jeu de
passes pour emporter à la victoire
on jouera également en fédérale 3
versailles aura l'occasion de se
rattraper de son début de saison
difficile ils recevront metz dimanche
prochain à 15 heures à domicile pour le
compte de la 3e journée du championnat
la victoire devrait être jouable pour
les versets y est mais cet avant dernier
du classement et à des gens cassé 88
points en deux matches ça devrait donc
être une formalité pour versailles le
trailer urbain de montier bretonneux est
programmée ce dimanche à partir de 9h30
au départ du centre sportif pierre de
coubertin la course traverse huit
quartiers de la commune pour un parcours
total de 13 km il sera également semé
d'embûches les 250 coureurs déjà
inscrits pourront tester leurs chevilles
et leur endurance sur la route dans des
chemins ils monteront également des
escaliers il y aura également des
courses pour les enfants et pour les
personnes handicapées à partir de 11h30
si les téléspectateurs qui nous écoutent
veulent s'inscrire et reste des places
on peut prendre son dossard 15 minutes
avant le début des épreuves en ferme
cette page sports part du basket trappe
reçoit viry-châtillon ce samedi à 20
heures au gymnase paul mallet à match
que les trappistes doivent remporter
pour effacer la défaite du week-end
dernier contre marly le roi en nationale
3 il avait perdu 81 à 64 à l'extérieur
pour ce premier match de la saison à
domicile les trappistes compte sur le
soutien du public pour remporter la
victoire mais également sur leur pivot
de 2 mètres 11 joués casseus c'est la
fin de 7,8 week-end je retrouve lundi
prochain pour les 7-8 sport très bon
week-end sur tv fil 78